- [Interviewer] All right, Alison.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Allison,
where are you from?
Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Bryan, Ohio.
- And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
growing up as a kid?
- No, I lived with my mom.
My parents got divorced
when I was about four
and my mom moved just around
from town to town in Ohio
with her husband she had.
(Allison chuckles)
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- It was pretty normal up
until towards my teenage years
then it started getting really abusive
'cause my mom married someone
that didn't like me very much,
and I ended up running away
from home when I was 16
and I never went back.
- [Interviewer] Did
you finish high school?
- No. I dropped out halfway
through my sophomore year.
- [Interviewer] And what
kind of teenager were you?
- I was a pretty normal
teenager I was really shy
not really outgoing at all.
I did sports but mostly did it just
'cause there was nothing else to do.
My town only had like 200 people in it.
- [Interviewer] Oh, small town.
- Yeah. So being different wasn't really
part of the itinerary.
So I tried to like mingle
as much as possible.
And when it just got too
rough I just up and left.
- [Interviewer] When you
say different, you mean?
- Oh I was a gay boy back then.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But I didn't really
like identify as a gay boy
I just like to identify as Adam,
and I wouldn't really
figure out what I really was
until like 10 years later.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah. And that was
about three years ago.
- [Interviewer] So this
is all fairly recent
that you realized who you are?
- Yeah, I used to actually
hate transgenders.
I thought they were
disgusting little creatures-
- [Interviewer] Really?
(Allison laughs)
- Yeah but I guess it was just
because I wanted to be them
and didn't know how to-
- [Interviewer] Yeah. There's
some interesting crossover
between people who hate transgenders
and those that are transgender.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's a blurred line.
- Very much so.
(Allison chuckles)
- [Interviewer] And you
came to California when?
- First time I moved
to California I was 18,
and I moved all around the United States
but I always ended up
coming back it was actually
like my 28th time living here.
It's the longest stint
I've ever lived here
but yeah, I came here for a rave.
(Allison chuckles)
- [Interviewer] And stayed?
- The first time yeah, from Utah.
- [Interviewer] Did you find
that being transgender out here
is a little more accepted
than back in small town Ohio?
- Well I've never actually went back,
I haven't seen anyone in my
family since I was 16 yeah.
The atmosphere is different,
I wouldn't say I'm more accepted
because sometimes I wish
I was still a gay boy
with the means how people interact with me
and how not accepted it
is really is really is.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Especially in the area that I live in.
- [Interviewer] You still get
roughed up and treated badly?
- Yeah. I mean on a daily
basis it's gotten really,
really bad actually I don't know why,
but I don't do anything to antagonize it
it's just me being there
and it's just it's weird.
It's just really weird.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Now
there's a lot of drugs
in this neighborhood are
you involved in any of that?
- I am. I started doing
Crystal when I was 16,
wasn't until I started shooting
up about seven years ago
that I became homeless and I was homeless
for like four years, got clean
and then started doing Black
and then eventually moved on to Fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] So now
you're using Fentanyl?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And Crystal, Meth as well?
- I use Crystal mostly for work.
- [Interviewer] So your work is?
- The Blade.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So you go over to the-
- No, not anymore I go up to Santa Monica.
- [Interviewer] Boulevard?
- Yeah, there's more money up there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
It's probably the bottom
of the barrel money down here.
- Yeah they want 20 bucks for everything.
(Allison laughs)
- [Interviewer] And on
Santa Monica, Boulevard,
you can make how much?
- Well I used to be able
to make on a weekday
like three to $500 and on a weekend like
it's pretty much no cap on the weekends.
It's anywhere between a 100
bucks to like 800 bucks,
a night.
But now with the pandemic
it's just there's nights
where I don't make anything.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah. 'Cause there's no one out there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I know. I understand.
But before the COVID thing broke out
what was your typical customer like?
- Mostly places. I don't
date black guys not
'cause I'm racist just
cause I've had very negative interactions,
and a lot of guys from the
studios is what I prefer
oddly enough I don't like to
get into cars really nice cars
because they generally don't
have a lot of cash on hand
and they wanna do things
before they pay me
and then they end up
paying me like nothing.
So that's happened like once or twice
so I'd rather get in a car
that's like all wrinkety
'cause they have cash on hand and yeah
so basically it's the
lower class is my clients
because they generally are the only ones
that they don't have banks
so all their money's on hand.
- [Interviewer] They have cash on them?
- Yeah, you can work 'em out of it.
(Allison laughs)
- [Interviewer] And have you
had bad experiences doing this?
- I had way bad experiences
there was one time I got
hospitalized because i don't
really know what happened
I just remember getting in the car
and then waking up on the pavement.
And I think he sucker
punched me in the face.
- [Interviewer] Rough you up?
- Yeah, but he left all my money
and he left me on the
sidewalk with all my stuff
so I think that's just how he got off.
- [Interviewer] He just
wanted to beat you up
- Yeah. And I've dealt
with a few guys like that.
- [Interviewer] Do you
get arrested sometimes?
- I've never gotten arrested
but I date one of the cops over here.
So he pretty much said he gave me
out of anything as long
as it's not a felony.
- [Interviewer] That's nice.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What is the
hardest part of your lifestyle?
Is it the danger?
- The hardest part is just
sometimes it's just walking
out the door 'cause you knew
that something's gonna happen.
- [Interviewer] Is it the
self-esteem hit that you take?
- Yeah. I used to have
really high self-esteem
when I first started it was empowering.
It was the kind of thing that I never got
when I came out of the
closet as being gay,
and so that empowering
feeling is just kind
of slowly been dwindled down
to where like it takes longer
to get out that door.
- [Interviewer] And what
emotions do you deal with mostly?
Is it anxiety?
Is it anger?
Is it depression?
- It's awkwardness.
Like that's just pretty
much what I deal with
'cause I don't wanna be awkward
but people make me awkward.
- [Interviewer] You feel awkward?
- Yeah. And I just wanna be normal.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- I have a friend.
- [Interviewer] Good friends?
- I have one good friend in Long Beach.
He's the one that helped
me off the streets.
He used to be a counselor
at the McIntosh House
or Mc Intyre House.
And yeah, he helped me.
He helped me by not helping
me, by cutting me off
'cause he used to be my connect.
And, then he just kind of like
he's been the most
stable person in my life
since before I ran away.
So, yeah he's the only person
I would consider a friend.
- [Interviewer] And these
interactions with the guys
that you pick up how do they go?
Are they just quick?
- Yeah. Once they bust their gun.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(Allison laughs)
How many of those do you do in a night?
- On a good night I'll
do like eight or 12,
but on a slow night
it's like five at least.
I won't get off the
Blade unless I have five.
- [Interviewer] Do you recall
your first time doing this?
- I think so. I remember being awkward.
I was not a girl
(Allison laughs)
but it's actually
what got me into being trans
and realizing that that's who I was,
was because girls made
more money on the Blade,
than any other gender.
So it's what got me being
comfortable with it.
I used to runaway when the sun came out
and put on my boy clothes and-
(Allison laughs)
- [Interviewer] A lot of
the guys that pick you up
on the download you think?
- Some of them are, some of them aren't,
they're mostly all drug users.
Like, Oh, I don't know if I could say this
I don't wanna say it
but I have a really high profile client.
- [Interviewer] This is somebody famous?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Don't name names.
- Yeah, but it's really nice
'cause he's the only one
I've ever encountered
and just to find out that like
he does really raunchy shit.
(Allison laughs)
- [Interviewer] So he's
not known as somebody
who would do this?
- No.
(Allison laughs)
It just kind of sheds a
light on the other side.
(Allison laughs)
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I think
there's probably some secrets
that some people have.
- Oh yeah he has a lot of 'em.
(Allison laughs)
- [Interviewer] But what
you do to support yourself
does it change the way
you view people or men?
- It doesn't change the way I view anybody
because everyone has their vices.
I'd be calling it kind of black if I did
but it has changed how
I'm able to interact
'cause now it's really hard
for me to be in a relationship
with a guy without being money involved.
And it's hard for me to
see having sex with a guy
without some kind of exchange going.
And it's really hurt me in that aspect
'cause I never had sex for the fun of it.
It was always I was getting
something out of it.
- [Interviewer] So far any
relationship that's just-
- Just love is hard.
- [Interviewer] Nothing else?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Would
be difficult for you?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You need the
money to make you feel loved?
- I don't know-
- [Interviewer] If it's for real?
- Yeah. And I don't like that.
It's something that I really feel
like it has handicapped me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah you've created it
by doing this for money.
- And I created it all on my own.
I'll just work through it.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
dreams when you were young
of doing something with your life?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of stuff did you envision?
- I was expecting to be
like graduating from school
like I wanted to be a
prosecuting attorney.
And I tried to do everything
to like set that up,
but everything's just always fell through,
I was always moving,
I was never stationary
in one place for too long.
- [Interviewer] So where you've ended up
does that cause shame for you?
- It hasn't caused me shame
'cause I don't think of it
that way or else I'll get
like wrapped up in depression.
I try to look at the
bright side of everything,
in that this is everything
I'm going through right now
is just gonna empower me, and
put me in a better situation,
but there is shame 'cause
I'm like almost I am 30
and I haven't done anything of my life.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- Best time of my life.
It was pretty much when I
first came out of being trans
'cause I just felt like
I can capture the world.
- [Interviewer] Was it liberating?
- Yeah, it was 'cause I finally
knew what was wrong with me.
(Allison laughs)
- [Interviewer] And do the
drugs make the situation
more difficult for you?
- It hasn't made it more difficult
'cause it's my coping mechanism now.
But when I lose weight
it does become a problem
because people automatically associate
that living where I live at with drugs,
it can never be anything other than that.
But it probably has if you
probably talked to somebody
that knows me they
probably would say it has,
but I don't see how it has.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Yeah, I was in a relationships
when I was a gay boy
but I haven't really been in one
since I tried getting in one
but he was okay with me working
and I didn't like that 'cause I felt like
he didn't respect me.
And I keep on getting guys like that.
They're okay with me working on the Blade.
- [Interviewer] So you
would rather find somebody
who wasn't okay with that?
- Wasn't okay with it.
Yeah, 'cause then I felt like
you would actually love me.
- [Interviewer] Where do you
think you'll be in five years?
- Probably in the same spot.
Hopefully going to school.
But I really don't know.
Everything's up in the air right now.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
have contact with your family?
- Yeah. I talked to my mom.
She recently moved to South Carolina
after my grandma died this year
so she's living with her third husband.
Yeah, she's doing good.
My brother is living with
her, he just had a baby.
So she's dealing with a kid.
So she's okay.
- [Interviewer] She accepts
your lifestyle and all that?
- Yeah, she didn't at first
and it wasn't that she didn't accept it
she didn't know how to
accept it 'cause she kept
on calling me my other name
and then (indistinct) her son
and I actually found out
earlier this year that she went
through a whole little phase where like,
she was stuck 'cause she
felt like she lost something
and she did, she lost her son.
And I didn't understand
that for a really long time.
But she really embraced having a daughter
and yeah, she's okay she's
probably my number one supporter.
It hurts her that I haven't
been around her for so long.
- [Interviewer] And how
do you define success?
But what would make you feel successful?
- By touching as many people as possible.
That's what I think is successful.
Doing something that
impacts someone's life.
And if you could do
that with so many people
you're successful.
- [Interviewer] And what
would you say is the
most important thing you've
learned in your 30 years?
- [Allison] Patience.
(Allison deeply exhales)
That's probably the most important.
I was never patient when I was a kid.
I always had to be right
now, and it's just patience.
Everything will happen when
it's supposed to happen.
As long as you do the footwork.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Well Allison thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Very
nice getting to know you.
I wish you the best of luck.
- Thanks.